fait de plus pour la yole robertine eu à
faire ch en flore s'impose par trois
fois et s'adjuge la coupe de martinique
une victoire dédiée à charles exil s'est
encore pas ton cas laissez moi c'est une
histoire de laguiole modération si
surnommé toujours le titre de la mer le
titre les deux des hommes quoi sert
décembre quitter c'est vraiment dur y
est très violent sur quinze au départ
des anses d'arlet des conditions de
navigation réunis comme de coutume le
public est présent au rendez vous le
tour de martinique 6 qui se suit sur la
première au transistor en tout cas sous
l'eau c'est la bagarre pour la gagne et
qui domine ses adversaires caracoli eux
vous aurez compris l'ufr avec ses 80
mètres carrés de voilure qui est le vent
à sa guise nombreuses moins voilées
parmi n'ont pas eu cette chance comme
rosette semaine à prendre cddm qui ont
coulé ufr brasse qui détenteur du
trophée
une lutte fratricide sur les trois
courses trois courses où la marine oise
se classe deuxième
est ce dû au manque d'énergie
on a nos garçons de 16 ans quand même
une augmentation de 2 ans donc
[Musique]
mais sinon on sait pas quand même avec
lui c'est vrai que sans coupe de
martinique s'est tous bien on parle
jamais du deuxième et il fallait tout
tenter à vous et abondante et
effectivement nous devons y croire a été
le monde même arraché mais en tout cas
il faudra se méfier de chaabi nom sumach
ecks sont pas trop reste optimiste pour
la suite
ubuntu pas son physique et morale il me
voilà après il ya le trou le trouvent y
arrive il faut connaître le podium
il ya des victoires d'étapes et deux
passes à prendre dimanche 14 juillet à
la trinité dernière manche du
championnat avant le tour ufr et braz
qui seront encore en compétition serrée
car légaux bertino que deux points
d'avancé sur les marinois le 14 à moitié
ça la trinité